if I say the planets are aligned what do
you think that means we have Mercury
Venus Earth Mars Jupiter Saturn and then
you have Uranus and Neptune all of those
planets orbit the Sun in about the same
plane which was a deep hint to tell us
how the solar system formed and so it
was concluded maybe we started from a
big gas cloud that collapsed into this
pancake the planets formed let's go down
to earth and look up into the sky where
are you going to find all the planets
half the stuff is going to be in the sky
when you're looking up because we are on
a ball you look at one side one side of
the ball and you see half of what's out
there seeing half the sky because okay
the other side of the ball is looking at
the other half it's not going to repeat
for hundreds of thousands of years every
single day is that
foreign
[Music]